[Music]
[Applause]
uh John warthine Sports Illustrated
executive editor senior writer and 60
Minutes correspondent of course just
spent some time with Dion Sanders and he
joins us now what was the game plan if
Colorado had lost to Colorado State John
as far as 60 Minutes airing your
interview
yeah let me uh let me show you the
Google Doc I wrote it about one in the
morning Eastern time on uh on Sunday
morning when they were down 11 and we
had to quickly ad-lib about how despite
this impressive start maybe some of the
passion's been cooled after a surprising
uh yeah
um there were okay candidly there were
there were some nervous moments there in
the fourth uh you know with uh we've got
10 minutes left but uh well all good but
you were going to run that no matter
what even if they lost to Colorado State
yeah I mean honestly like the the promos
go out and uh it's kind of too late to
pull back
um and I I mean honestly I I think the
larger thesis would have held right this
is a guy shaking up college sports and
he's really leaning into all these
changes and he's like charismatic guy
but yeah it would uh it would have been
sub-optimal if they had suffered a home
loss uh when they were 20 whatever Point
favorites any difference in Dion from
the last time he was profiled at Jackson
State to now at Colorado
yeah it's that's a good question yeah in
some ways
very you know like exactly the same guy
um a lot of sort of very familiar tropes
and in other ways it's really hard to
exaggerate just how different a job this
is going from the mission of elevating
all these historically black not just
Jackson State but all these hbcus to
suddenly this guy is playing Power five
football and it's all about it's it's
recruiting and nil and conference
realignment I mean it's really hard to
exaggerate sort of the and some places
same guy same job same care you know
same Charisma but it's a really
different job than what he had uh eight
months ago do you pitch the story when
you first profiled him with Jackson
State you have to pitch this to 60
minutes and say what about this and then
how does it work with uh this story
emerging this past Sunday
um yeah my producer Dragon mahilovich
we're sort of talking it's like you know
what I I know we just did this guy but
he's kind of relevant and it's a kind of
a different company and uh it was like
why do we why don't we give this uh why
don't we give us a shot in a new
location
um as far as he said the mission you
know the job was accomplished at Jackson
State you know like why leave and I
think he said you know I I've done what
I was supposed to do uh were you
satisfied with that answer that this is
why he he had done everything he was
what was the mission of Jackson State
yeah I mean we we talked about that a
lot last year and he sort of said look
I'm not one of these these climber
crouches that wants to make it up the
ladder and I'm not I don't need the
money he really leaned into the mission
and here was that he'd never been to
Jackson Mississippi he went there he was
very moved here was this historically
black school he talked a lot about how
players that came to come here Travis
Hunter they would be part of
setting a different path this wasn't
just hey this is the best school that
recruiting me for the fattest nil deal
he really leaned into the mission the
city was going through a Water Crisis I
mean I can't describe I can't exaggerate
how big a deal this was in Jackson
Mississippi
um I mean honestly he kind of tiptoed
around it I think he got a bit
frustrated
um I think not everyone has his uh his
drive and ambition and I think he's sort
of at some point sort of threw up his
hands and said I've done all I can do
here but um yeah I mean it's it's tough
look we've seen this all the time right
I mean what coach doesn't want a better
job we all know that you go from school
a to school B he positioned himself and
look I don't need to be playing this
game I don't care what they're paying me
it's pocket change to me anyway this is
about something much bigger than getting
to the next big college football job
did Prime Academy come up at any time in
any of your interviews with him
yeah it did it did in Jackson and I sort
of said you know what's you've got some
answering to do and he essentially said
it was one of the best things that's
happened to me because I learned what
I'm good at I learned what I'm not good
at I'm learned I made mistakes and I
won't uh repeat again and I I thought he
actually you know we pushed him he asked
and answered and we moved on yeah
because I had an athletic director of a
school that had an opening and he said
that that that he kept coming back to
this Prime Academy this high school that
Dion started and it fell apart for a
variety of reasons but that made him
very cautious about wanting to hire
Deion Sanders I don't know if that
happened with any other universities
including his alma mater but I do think
it played a role at least with one
athletic director could you see that
happening
so I
I you're giving up some power if you're
the A.D
um he's doing I mean as far as I can
everything is legitimate everything's
within the guidelines but you can see it
even in Colorado I mean this is not your
standard higher and for some of these
ads that like to have uh you know like
the oversee the football team and they
want to consolidate things
um you know I think it's it's takes a
certain kind of A.D who's willing to
take a risk on the personality as big as
that what is his role at Colorado
yeah it's a good question and
I was a little we asked him that and
just sort of said look I see your
business card I see your title what is a
head football coach at a school like
this
and there were you know I think he sees
himself in some cases as a father figure
to some of these kids some of this is
X's and O's I mean I actually was really
impressed this is not just someone who
shows up and watches practice for 15
minutes and then
goes out to lunch with boosters I mean
he's really all in on the football part
but I think he also sees himself as a
CEO and you know you go on you go on the
website for Colorado football and
there's a little dollar sign icon next
to the players and
he's very transactional and very
rational and some of this is about
making money for the school and some of
this is about the athletic department
some of this is about
he wants these kids to get paid
appropriately and he wants these kids to
be well set up when they're done playing
um I mean the idea that he's just sort
of a figurehead and he's this
charismatic celebrity and this is Hall
of Famer I was impressed at Jackson when
I saw the level of his involvement not
just with sort of play calling and
practice but he knew which kids came
from single family homes single parent
homes in Wicked I mean he knows who
transferred from where and this kid's a
junior everybody's got sophomore
eligibility he really knows this team
and I think that's something that might
get overlooked yeah there was a moment
where there was a little push back from
you
um you know where you challenged him a
little bit you know being honest my
problem the only problem I had the way
Dion came in was
you can get rid of players you can get
rid of coaches don't do that on camera
and I thought that that was unfair to
those kids that if you hey you're you
won one game you're not in my future get
packing
um but you know you can't have a video
of that of doing that to these kids and
that's that's been my only knock on him
you know with what he did he came in he
cleaned house okay don't do it on camera
I'm kicking myself I wish I'd after that
really good point don't humiliate these
I mean you know it's not like they're
signing consent forms too when the
cameras are rolling I mean everything he
does there's you know he's very good on
social media which I think is something
else I mean I think a lot of programs
are going to be playing catch-up
honestly whether it's nil or whether
it's the docu-series or whether it's you
know using that transfer portal
um their cameras everywhere and you
never know is it for for his own feed is
this for Colorado is this for this
Amazon docu-series but everything he
does is on camera right that's that's
actually a really good point 19 year old
kids you're going to chase them out you
can do that behind closed doors all
right are you last time we had John you
were going to Wimbledon and you were
going to work on Novak Djokovic
um and I don't know where that stands
but also I'm gonna guess you being uh
the parapathetic reporter correspondent
that Lionel Messi would be maybe on your
menu
I uh
I gotta tread careful here uh I like
your instincts
um the concurrent multimedia projects
he's involved in uh uh yeah it would be
great if Lionel Messi called this
afternoon and said uh he's in I'd be in
okay what about jokes
um yeah it's just I mean honestly I I
remember saying yeah I think that's just
a question of timing but I think um man
he's done pretty well since we that was
about like six weeks ago and he's added
uh added another major to us all doing
pretty well for 36. good to talk to you
again John thanks for joining us
anytime thank you that's John worthon
Sports Illustrated executive editor
senior writer and of course
correspondent for 60 minutes